okay riley riley welcome back
hello how you been it's been six six
seven months since we
talked to you i think it's been nine no
it's last summer
it's been eight yeah probably around
that april march
april i really enjoyed your last talk
because you you you're so well spoken
so intelligent you speak so beautifully
about what you've been through and what
you're going through
tell me what's going on now where are
you at um
i suppose since
the last time we spoke i've been
struggling with
the want or need to get into treatment
or let alone even get out of los
angeles you're leaving you were leaving
for rehab the day when you did the last
interview
i thought i was but um
turned out the girl i was with
they they pretty much just all lied to
me so that they could get her into
treatment and
i wasn't along for the ride on that one
so it is what it is
but recently actually what's funny is
i'm planning on going to orange county
to go
through a treatment center down there
as soon as possible really excellent
you spoke a lot last time about what
your childhood was like and the abuse
you
got from your from your dad and the more
i've learned
since that talk that that's everything
that's
that's the stat that's the where it's
the core where it all stems from
all this abuse all the drug addiction
all the
all the self-destruct self-destruction
you see on my channel
kind of stems from that i would call it
rewiring of your brain
when you get that kind of abuse right
and then it's almost like your efforts
to do the right thing
just get turned upside down by your
self-destructive nature and
there you are back in on the street
again
uh yeah that's
basically what's been going on lately i
moved to north hollywood for a while
and then recently a month and a half ago
i moved back here
because i ruined the housing situation i
was in over there
like i had one opportunity to
take from somebody that i shouldn't have
and i [ __ ] did it like
i took the chance you know what i mean i
weighed my options and i took the chance
and they knew immediately it was me
because i'm not gonna
lie about it when i'm confronted and
like i was like yeah i did that
and that's how it's been for me i'll go
like two months three months
everything good make the right choices
and then i'll make one wrong
decision and my consequences are bad
usually very bad
is is stealing in your nature or is it
just the drugs that make you
do this kind of stuff it's the
the lack of finances lately in the last
eight weeks i haven't been
had any access to my money through
unemployment because they cancelled my
card and
i've been having troubles getting it
back in the mail for some reason
so that lack of any money to survive at
all
has which i've
been out in the past
it's just been like crucial like [ __ ]
up like i can't
it's i've almost died because of this
because i have no money you know what i
mean
and i don't like to steal but when i see
an opportunity
to do something where i can make money
for survival
for the drugs i need for the food i need
for the housing i need
sometimes i take that chance and last
time you were using heroin
right with is that continued i still
sometimes do um
with within the last month i've started
using
fentanyl i started smoking it
i don't know how much better or worse
that is
because i smoke that and i don't shoot
it but
it's much more strong
and it when i don't have it it's i feel
even worse
and it's scaring me uh
the progression of it is very really
scaring me
and i just that's what's pushing me to
quit
right now to go to rehab again because i
know if i continue
with the fentanyl it's gonna get really
bad really quick
and pretty soon when i don't have it i'm
not going to be able to move
which is a scary place to be in i don't
want nothing controlling me like that
and you're intelligent enough to know
better but it's not about
intelligence here is it
it tell me about drug addiction
from a standpoint well just it's it's
it's such a
it's a conniving thing it doesn't matter
if you're the smartest or dumbest person
on earth
uh you could be the smartest person on
earth and have no
addiction in your in your family and
have a good upbringing
and do heroin ten times and not be
addicted
or you could have the same situations
and do it once and become addicted so
it's really [ __ ] confusing
it doesn't make any sense um
[Music]
i think everyone's just different and
our brains are wired differently
and sometimes we use it we'll use
something and we'll discover it
to be a crutch very quickly
and i think that's that determining
factor of
whether or not we become addicts or not
it's a i think uh environment has a lot
more to do with it now
than i ever thought before environment
being
like your your current environment or
surroundings yeah like this city for
instance
even famous people do like um
methamphetamine
it's like normal it's people are used to
it it's okay
you know i thought that was really
[ __ ] weird but i found that out one
night
uh because it's a very popular drug in
the city
first on that right yeah it's not so
much cocaine anymore like it was
it's more uh crystal meth
and i've realized that i'm not so much
i'm not doing that as much anymore
because i feel weird
on it there's got to be something else
in it that
just doesn't make me feel right what did
the crystal meth
do for you um well i've been
tested on like a 16 panel test
after i know that i've just been using
heroin and meth
and i've popped for five different drugs
like mdma
um i don't even remember
i don't even remember but there was two
hallucinogenics and then
pcp methamphetamine and amphetamine
and that's just from the meth and so if
that's what's in there
like why would i want to introduce that
to my body anymore
i'm not sure you know exactly what
you're buying on the street anyway no
no and i'm not sure i should be doing
that anyways that's right
it's just it's yeah do you think if you
went to this orange county rehab
and somehow got clean or got in a much
better place
we're using a lot less perhaps with
suboxone or whatever
that that in combination with some
therapy to work out what you went
through as
a child might get you to a point where
you're not so
prone to reuse well i'll be honest here
i think it all came down to my
my relationship with my ex and and my
son and that whole
catastrophe is what
kept me sick for so long i think now
that she
made it so we're separated i finally
have the chance to think about myself
and actually if i'm going to go to rehab
and have the ability to think about
myself and only that because i'm not
going to be worried about a relationship
i no longer have
if that makes sense at this point i'm
just worried about
being a part of my son's life
you know because she's gotten custody
back
within the last month because she's been
clean for a month
and or a year and two months
and so now i have this opportunity where
i can selfishly do it and it might
actually work
and that's a scary thing for me so at
the same time i don't want to do it
which doesn't make any sense either but
the life you're living now you're living
on the street yeah
in a town
uh recently no you just i've been
here and there at people's places in
apartments or
on the street uh rarely in apartments
maybe twice
a week and mainly on the streets at
buddies places because
uh it's just been real dangerous lately
[Music]
the night down here is a very different
scene than during the day yeah
yeah it's scary man and you better make
sure that you don't [ __ ] anyone over
because people have ability to make
things happen that would be out of
anyone's imagination
and it's really scary
addiction's such a perplexing
thing for an outsider to to watch
because it's like i see very clearly how
you could be living a great life
with your kid with your you know repair
the relationship with your ex
get everything together do whatever it
takes to get your life together
and yet the blocks that you have that
you're experiencing right now are so
strong that
you just can't you're smart enough to
figure that out you just can't
it seems yeah
i i even have somebody that's willing to
come like pick me up
at any time within a day's notice
to take me to orange county and i can't
seem to find
the the the right day
the courage to do it really is it
courage yeah
i think i'm just afraid but what i'm
learning with every
all of these issues that you see all
these problems people are experiencing
on my channel
that courage is is is very close to the
core of all of it
yeah lack of lack of courage stops you
the fear of what might happen the fear
of getting clean the fear of living
being successful in life being fulfilled
it's uncomfortable
is it because you don't deserve it you
feel like you don't deserve it
honestly i felt like i deserved
everything i used to feel like i
deserved a lot more than i got
and at this point where i'm at
now i do think i deserve a little bit
more than i have
but yeah
but i also put myself in these
situations
i could be gone i mean [ __ ] i walk like
nine miles a day i
i could be out of la in a day you know
it's not that hard um
[Music]
but the lifestyles just it becomes such
a
routinely thing
and you start making friends with people
and when i came back here i was very
welcomed by
much of the community which was shocking
to me you came back downtown
yeah which was pretty shocking everyone
was really happy to see me
but i think it was for the wrong reasons
um
but that you know we're in it together
out there you know what i mean
and the people who live out here that
have it better than us
[Music]
they really have a hard time
understanding
or even wanting to connect thoughts like
they don't want to connect with me they
don't want to
understand what it's like for me who was
much recently
in their shoes now homeless
which a lot of people are becoming
because of coronavirus
but people are starting to figure out
that
soon i mean if [ __ ] gets worse with
coronavirus and all that stuff
a lot more people are going to become
homeless and be in the same situation
i'm
in and it just gets bad because then
you're introduced to drugs and alcohol
and [ __ ]
prostitution and whatever
illegal everything the drugs numb the
pain of whatever you're going through
yeah it's the thing to do it makes the
time go by
and i don't have to think about what a
piece of [ __ ] i am if i'm high
that's really what it comes down to
because i can't even run out of dope
without
i start freaking out if i'm gonna run
out of dope
because i know i'll start thinking
and i'll start feeling and that's just
where i'm at now
well riley i wish you the best of luck
hope you make it to orange county
hope you find the courage to do it and
stick with it
and complete it yeah get back to seattle
is that where your son is
i think i'm going to stay out here
because my ex has a place in
san clemente now with your son i would
i would like to uh probably move out to
orange county yeah
that's a beautiful place yeah
all right wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much